nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 lors du choix comme chaque
soir à 20h15 heure de paris avec vous
ashwin verdien bonsoir bonsoir j - 6
avant le premier tour oui et les
candidats étaient sur le pont le
week-end dernier pour lancer toutes
leurs forces dans cette dernière ligne
droite avant le premier tour huit
d'entre eux était en meeting ce sont
parfois même succédé au même endroit les
quatre autres candidats étaient en
déplacement objectif martelé leur
programme décocher les dernières flèches
et pour certains déjà envisager l'après
présidentielle aurait cap politique est
signée florent au dos et fabrice bihan
c'est l'histoire d'un ancien président
dont le nom est hué par son propre camp
nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]
son manque de soutien à valérie pécresse
est toujours en travers de la gorge de
certains militants et l'air pas
rancunière du moins en public la
candidate elle érige en grande figure de
la droite nous le sommes et seul
héritier du général de gaulle de jacques
chirac nicolas sarkozy la droite
emmanuel macron marine le pen eric
zemmour sont les faux seins nous en
sommes nous les négateurs en coulisses
c'est lui le plus proche de nicolas
sarkozy
emmanuel matheron voulait que son unique
meeting de campagne et des airs de match
de football aulas des ténors macro nist
et appelle à la mobilisation générale
contre l'extrême droite
de trop des contrôles ont rempli
le combat
du patriotisme
contre les nationalistes lui c'est la
place du capitole qui la remplit à
toulouse jean-luc mélenchon compte bien
faire payer au président-candidat ses
liens étroits avec le cabinet de conseil
mckinsey qui estime que le nombre
d'articles de presse sur mac kinsey
suffisant pour qu'une enquête
préliminaire soit engagée et de la
traite
dans cette dernière ligne droite il veut
à tout prix éviter que ses électeurs
fils chez l'insoumis enfants à nanterre
visite de soutien à ces militants pour
l'écologiste yannick jadot c'est quoi
l'essentiel c'est le climat c'est la
santé c'est les services publics justice
sociale c'est le pouvoir d'achat mais
que le vote efficace
le match du 10 avril n'ai pas joué c'est
la conviction d'eric zemmour qui n'a pas
pu finir le sien à aix en provence
s'il a été expulsé par le gérant le
frère de zinedine zidane mécontents de
sa présence
originaire du pays basque lui est plus
rugby jean lassalle l'assurent il sait
ce dont la france a besoin elle ne
cherche pas forcément être
extrêmement droitisée elle ne cherche
pas à être extrêmement gauchisé elle ne
cherche pas être extrêmement trop misé
elle cherche tout simplement à
ceux
du rouge du rouge et encore du rouge
celui des anticapitalistes
double meeting de nathalie arthaud et
philippe poutou à paris et à chacun sa
cible des travailleurs qu'ils voteraient
le pen ou zemmour pour écarter macro se
tirerait une balle dans le pied sur le
fond c'est moi le pen sont exactement
pareil tels les frères bogdanoff de la
politique macro 65 ans la retraite
vieilles idées de droite cette idée que
finalement parce que l'espérance de vie
augmente et b au cas où on se fait chier
à la retraite a pas travaillé et bien il
faut travailler plus longtemps
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
alors il ne reste donc six jours pour
convaincre les indécis et inciter les
abstentionnistes à aller voter oui et le
taux d'abstention premier tour pourrait
battre le record de 2002 selon un
sondage ipsos sopra steria publié tout à
l'heure 29 à 33 % des électeurs français
n'ont pas l'intention de prendre part
donc au vote du premier tour résultat
d'une campagne morne qui n'a pas réussi
à intéresser la population n'en parle ce
soir avec roselyne febvre la chef du
service politique de france 24 bonsoir
roselyne bonsoir je l'abstention risque
donc d'être très élevé oui très élevé
déjà dans les intentions on va dire
d'abstention ailes et alla 30% selon les
sondages en 2022 en début de 17 par dont
elle était de 22% au premier tour et en
2012 à 20 % donc vous voyez que et bien
ça c'est rod la participation s'érode au
fil du temps en 2002 vous parlez de 2002
qui était le record c'était 28 %
d'abstention alors va-t-on atteindre ces
sommets c'est toute la question c'est
peut-être probable pourtant c'est
l'élection préférée des français avec la
présidentielle avec les municipales mais
il ya toujours ce petit refrain dans le
fond pourquoi les gens ne veulent pas
voter un parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
plié 2 que les promesses ne sont jamais
tenues et puis qu'est gosselies et ce
mouvement de balancier un coup à droite
un coup à gauche même si maintenant
cette bipolarité n'est plus la même il
ya une bipolarité son regarde les
sondages mais mais en gros c'est tout le
monde dans le même panier car
l'abstention il n'est pas nouvelle mais
elle ne cesse de progresser oui elle
n'est pas nouvelle et vous allez voir
quelle date depuis bien longtemps déjà
mais ça commence dans les années 80 je
parlais tout à l'heure de ce mouvement
de balancier un coup à droite un coup à
gauche avec des français qui ont le
sentiment que quelle que soit la droite
ou la gauche de toute façon ça ne change
pas la vie des français et surtout
aujourd'hui les jeunes assument de ne
pas voter alors ce qui est intéressant à
cheval c'est que tout à l'heure quand on
a fait le facebook live il y avait la
question d'un internaute qui demandait
mais est ce qu'on est vraiment un
citoyen lorsque on ne va pas voter eh
bien j'ai retrouvé une phrase qui était
écrit dans l'événement en 1938 à ne pas
confondre avec les accords de munich
bien évidemment où l'on reparle un petit
peu en ce moment et il était écrit le
citoyen qui dans une démocratie tient en
main cette arme redoutable qu'on appelle
le bulletin de vote et qui par
indifférence par paresse par crainte
n'eussent pas de son droit des lecteurs
trail en même temps que ses propres
intérêts ceux de la république elle même
donc vous voyez déjà à l'époque que la
critique était extrêmement sévère et
aujourd'hui dans le fond on dira qu'on
va pas voter vingt personnes va vous
dire elle pas un citoyen et cette
critique sera un peu bas oui je te
comprends tu vas pas voter bien
évidemment moi non plus j'irai pas voter
voyez enfin s'aplatissent produit ça
passe à un peu mieux alors qu'à l'époque
eh bien c'était mal vu alors quel
candidat pourrait pâtir le plus de cette
abstention
eh bien le pen et mélenchon pourquoi
parce qu'ils en ont ferait une fête et
ils en ont fait les frais l'une marine
le pen en régionale en 2021 tous les
sondages et bien prédisait que son parti
raflerait deux voire trois régions
résultat ça a été 0 en 2019 pour les
élections
européennes et bien idem pour jean luc
mélenchon qui en a fait l'amère
expérience
60% de son électorat ne s'est pas
déplacé et puis il faut le savoir dans
l'électorat jeune on dit on va voter
intel intel oui c'est sympathique parce
que c'est les extrêmes mais on ne vote
pas ou peu et puis il ya un risque aussi
pour le candidat en tête dans les
sondages sont les règles de son
électorat pense que l'élection est pliée
donc là aussi danger merci beaucoup
roselyne pour cet éclairage et on vous
retrouve dès demain dans mardi politique
merci rosine on va jeter un coup d'oeil
maintenant h rennes au sondage oui et
pas grand chose ne bouge selon un
sondage ipsos sopra steria publié cet
après midi emmanuel macron est toujours
en tête avec 26 et demi pour cent des
voix l'écart se resserre encore d'un
petit point par rapport à vendredi
dernier avec marine le pen crédité
désormais de 21% des voix 16% du côté de
jean-luc mélenchon à gauche maintenant
fabien roussel est crédité de trois et
demi pourcent anne hidalgo plafonne
toujours à 2% la candidate socialiste
qui a tenu son dernier meeting dimanche
à l'issue d'une campagne aux airs de
chemin de croix
malgré l'investiture du parti socialiste
sous la bannière duquel françois
hollande était pourtant parvenu à la
présidence il ya 10 ans sa campagne à
elle n'a jamais décollé et l'urgence
maintenant c'est d'empêcher
l'effondrement pure et simple du ps soit
il ce reportage signé maya anaïs iata
guen et fadil bayat
dernier tour de piste pour aller
chercher l'inespéré remontada
quelques socialistes de premier rang
font bonne figure mais pas de prise de
parole le soldat hidalgo est bel et bien
seul au fond
[Applaudissements]
les congés payés en 1936 la section
syndicale d'entreprise c'est nous
qui a créé les comités d'entreprise
fondé la sécurité sociale est tendue
encore les droits des travailleurs
seniors
souvenirs d'un passé radieux quand les
socialistes faisait plus que 2 % dans le
secondaire quand on connaît la qualité
des propositions qu'elles portent par
rapport à ce qui est prédit il ya un
décalage important qui est
fondamentalement injuste quand même et
aux dernières régionales le ps a quand
même fait un bon pourcentage et je
comprends pas qu'elle est qu'elle en est
à 2 % non pour mélenchon maintenant
parce que mélenchon il il a bon il ya
des algues des idées qui sont qui sont
oui séduisante mais ils peuvent être
appliquées lors ça sert à quoi créée du
tout
la gauche au gouvernement
c'était il ya à peine dix ans quand pour
la deuxième fois un président socialiste
entrée à l'elysée
en 2017 ténor électeurs du parti parti
chez emmanuel macron nous laissant à
benoît hamon que 6% des voix au premier
tour j'ai joué à déjouer le désastre qui
s'annonce est depuis plusieurs mois et
peut-être plusieurs années à l'époque
c'est la stupéfaction et le début de la
crise financière aujourd'hui le ps en
est à espérer faire aussi bien et
notamment à atteindre la barre des 5%
synonymes de remboursement des frais de
campagne une situation plus critique que
jamais qui pousse les dirigeants
socialistes a évoqué une recomposition
qui souhaite pas il y avait de
l'ambiance est au contraire on puisse
rassembler la gauche je te défie quatre
ans la gauche at-elle été visé et bien
gnagne par les hommes peuvent passer les
choses peuvent être différentes mais la
social démocratie française a fait
beaucoup pour ce pays et elle va
continuer et un social démocrate
pourrait bien revenir sur scène françois
hollande absent à paris mais présent à
limoges il ya quelques semaines il y
avait annoncé son envie de reconstruire
une gauche de responsabilité
[Musique]
et enfin ce serait notre archive bonus
du jour oui deux archives en réalité sur
l'abstention qui on l'a dit risque de
battre des records cette année une
perspective qui inquiète les candidats
quel que soit leur bord politique des
candidats qui alerte d'ailleurs sur les
risques que ce nom votre fait peser sur
la démocratie un point de vue partagé
par de nombreux autres hommes politiques
dans le passé exemple avec deux
présidents jacques chirac et françois
hollande qu'on écoute tu aurais tout
j'ajoute que ceux qui s'abstiennent
perdent par définition toute espèce de
droit à critiquer ensuite si les choses
ne vont pas suis toujours un peu irrité
quand je vois des gens qui critiquent
l'action du gouvernement ou celle de
l'opposition
et quand je leur dis mais qu'est ce que
vous avez voté la dernière fois j'ai pas
voté je ne vous n'avez pas le droit de
critiquer de l'autre côté
que vous ne faisiez pas voter dimanche
j'espère l'abstention il espère la
désespérance de découragement la
résignation et bien vous devez vaincre
d'abord la résignation le découragement
le fatalisme et vous devez vous adresser
à toutes celles et tous ceux qui se
posent la question de l'utilité du bot
et c'est tout pour ce soir claire voilà
c'est la fin donc de france 2022 l'heure
du choix à retrouver bien sûr sur notre
site internet
www.francebillet.com et évidemment sur
les réseaux sociaux aussi merci beaucoup
je serais vraiment on vous retrouve
demain soir à la même heure 20h15 heure
de paris